De ser un personaje completamente desconocido
a convertirse en el mismísimo jefe de Estado…
Un salto que empieza a ser cada vez menos
infrecuente en la política internacional.
Queridos, amigos, amigas,
Ecuador tiene nuevo presidente…
Que ya os adelanto no lo tendrá nada fácil.
El que es uno de los países más pequeños de
Sudamérica, se enfrenta, sin embargo, a desafíos
titánicos. Ríete tú de los molinos de don Quijote.
Hablamos de narcotráfico, de conflictos
indigenistas y de una creciente oleada
de violencia y delincuencia que se
está extendiendo por todo el país.
N1(15 de octubre de 2023: Daniel Noboa,
heredero de un imperio empresarial,
gana la elección presidencial de Ecuador. NYTIMES)
Si bien la victoria de Noboa abre una nueva etapa
política en Ecuador, lo cierto es que sigue
habiendo muchos más interrogantes que certezas.
Especialmente por lo particular que
será este nuevo periodo de gobierno.
Mañana empezamos a trabajar para reconstruir
un país que ha sido gravemente golpeado por
la violencia, por la corrupción y por el odio,
desde mañana empieza a trabajar la esperanza,
desde mañana empieza a trabajar Daniel Noboa
su nuevo presidente de la república.
Noboa solo podrá terminar el mandato que le
correspondía terminar a Guillermo Lasso. Es decir,
que el nuevo presidente solo estará
frente al Ejecutivo ecuatoriano desde
diciembre de 2023 hasta mayo de 2025.
Su trabajo será, por tanto, una
carrera contrarreloj, con miles de
problemas, múltiples promesas y unos
recursos y plazos más bien justitos.
Es por eso que todos nos preguntamos
que significa realmente la llegada
de Daniel Noboa al poder en Ecuador:
¿Logrará llevar a cabo todas las reformas
prometidas en apenas 17 meses? ¿Logrará vencer
al narcotráfico y devolver la paz a Ecuador? ¿Qué
papel jugará el correísmo en toda esta aventura?
Pues bien, vamos con ello.
[Pero antes dejadme haceros dos
preguntas. La primera, ¿estáis ya suscritos
a VisualPolitik? Si no es así no esperéis
más es 100% gratis y podrás estar al tanto
de todo el contenido que está por llegar.
La segunda pregunta es muy clara: ¿podría
Ucrania llegar a convertirse en la promesa
económica de Europa? Sí, sé que hablamos
de un país en guerra, pero… ¿Podría Ucrania
convertirse en una especie de nueva Polonia?
Un centro de fabricación competitivo en las
puertas de Europa. Pues ojo porque hay muchos
argumentos para sostener esta afirmación. Si
quieres saber más no te pierdas el vídeo que
ha hecho a este respecto Si lo Hubiera Sabido,
el canal de información financiera de
Mutuactivos con el que participamos. En
él Alberto nos cuenta todos los detalles.
Os dejo el enlace en la descripción
y también al final de este vídeo]
Y ahora sí, continuemos con Noboa.
Queridos amigos, amigas, en mayo de
este 2023, el presidente Guillermo
Lasso sorprendió a todos cuando anunció
la aplicación de la “muerte cruzada” …
Este término trágico se utiliza para describir
un mecanismo constitucional que consiste en
la convocatoria adelantada de elecciones para
elegir un nuevo Poder Ejecutivo y Legislativo,
disolviendo así sus respectivos mandatos.
N2 (17 de mayo de 2023: Con la muerte
cruzada Guillermo Lasso ‘le devuelve
al pueblo el poder de decidir su
futuro en próximas elecciones’. El Universo)
Para Lasso, esta medida era la única opción de
un gobierno que en la práctica ya estaba muerto.
Desde 2022 el ejecutivo de Lasso se enfrentó a
varios impeachments y bloqueo legislativo que
hacía inviable cualquier acción de gobierno.
Para colmo, como ya os contamos, en febrero de
2023, Lasso perdió un referéndum constitucional,
con el que había sometido a consulta popular
diferentes ejes de su plan de gobierno.
Es decir, que Lasso no contaba ni con el
parlamento ni tampoco con la sociedad ecuatoriana.
Su administración estaba totalmente contra
las cuerdas. Y por eso el ya expresidente
vio en la muerte cruzada una vía institucional
para intentar salir del atolladero y, quizás,
escapar también de ese infierno político.
C1 (“He escogido gobernar seis meses en el
purgatorio en lugar de dos años
en el infierno”Guillermo Lasso)
Además, de paso, se llevaba por delante la
Asamblea Nacional dominada por la oposición.
El presidente debió decirse algo así como:
Si me voy yo, nos vamos todos.
Y, amigos… Dicho y hecho.
(Yo admito errores en mi gestión pero soy
un demócrata y he procurado que las
soluciones sean siempre
constitucionales y legales
he solicitado al consejo nacional
electoral la convocatoria
inmediata a elecciones legislativas y
presidenciales para el resto de los
respectivos periodos)
La cuestión es que Lasso no tenía ya ningún
capital político con el que poder apoyar a
un sucesor, así que la competición se abrió de
par en par con múltiples partidos y candidatos.
(Algunos candidatos independientes, como el
periodista Fernando Villavicencio comenzaron
a ganar altura, aunque su trágico asesinato
terminó empañando toda la campaña electoral.
Luego algún que otro perfil con alta
experiencia, como el ex vicepresidente de
Lenin Moreno, Otto Sonnenholzner, también
intentaron hacerse con la presidencia.
No obstante, la única plataforma que compitió
claramente desde el primer día fue Revolución
Ciudadana (RC), el partido correista que
tuvo a Luisa González como candidata.
Y en medio de semejante berenjenal, se fue
colando poco a poco un tal Daniel Noboa,
un candidato que hizo de la
discreción la clave de su éxito)
Primero nunca dijimos que estábamos
segundo porque el segundo siempre le
caen a palazos siempre lo insultan
siempre le dice o sea lo atacan lo ataca
todo el mundo
Noboa no solo logró pasar a la segunda vuelta
enfrentándose directamente al correísmo,
sino que logró hacerse con la victoria
final… Pero, ¿de dónde salió, exactamente,
Noboa? ¿Cuál es su ideología? ¿Cómo es que
logró ganarse la confianza del 52% de los
ecuatorianos en apenas unas pocas semanas?
Pues prestad mucha atención, porque el ahora
presidente más joven de la historia de Ecuador
ha tenido una carrera meteórica. Una carrera
que será clave para comprender la dirección
y el rumbo que adoptará su nuevo gobierno.
(T1: OUTSIDER… PERO NO TANTO)
Quizás Daniel Noboa Azín fuese un perfil
poco conocido para la opinión pública ecuatoriana,
pero desde luego ese no es el caso de su familia.
La familia del nuevo presidente está muy
presente en los círculos empresariales y
políticos del país. Lo están, incluso
desde hace varias generaciones.
Daniel forma parte de la tercera generación de
una familia de empresarios multimillonarios de
Guayaquil. Su abuelo, Luis Noboa Naranjo fundó
y gestionó la Exportadora Bananera Noboa,
un negocio que le permitió ser durante el siglo
XX uno de los hombres más ricos de Ecuador.
Luego el padre de Daniel, Álvaro Noboa
Pontón, expandió el negocio familiar
más allá bajo la insignia del Grupo Noboa,
creando un conglomerado muy diversificado
cuyas actividades van desde la agroexportación
hasta la gestión de negocios inmobiliarios.
Claro que esta diversificación no solo giró en
torno al ámbito privado. Álvaro fue un político
de gran peso hacia los 2000. De hecho, llegó
a ser candidato presidencial en 5 ocasiones e,
incluso, pasó ea 3 segundas vueltas.
(Álvaro Noboa obtuvo el 48% de los votos
en la segunda vuelta de 1998. En el año 2002
volvió a quedarse a las puertas de la presidencia,
se hizo con el 45%. En el año 2006 tuvo
su última elección competitiva, llegó a
una segunda vuelta donde se encontró con un joven
político… un tal Rafael Correa. Nada que hacer)
Luego, por otro lado, Annabella Azín,
la esposa de Álvaro y madre de Daniel,
llegó a acompañar la fórmula presidencial
de la familia en 2009 y 2013.
Digamos que los Noboa querían a
toda costa la presidencia y la
rozaron en tres ocasiones. Ahora la han
conseguido de la mano de su hijo Daniel,
quien no era alguien visiblemente
ligado a todo ese legado político.
Sea como sea su pertenencia a la familia Noboa
lo vincula directamente con las elites sociales,
económicas y diferentes círculos de
poder en Ecuador. No hablamos, por tanto,
del típico outsider que aparece de la nada.
Ahora bien, ¿Qué hay de su vida? Pues si
os parece echamos un vistazo muy rápido.
(Con tan solo 36 años, Daniel Nobia estudió
Administración de Negocios en la Universidad
de Nueva York (NYU Stern School of Business); y
también obtuvo un título de Administración
Pública en la Harvard Kennedy School y otro
título en Gobernanza y Comunicación Política
por la Universidad George Washington. Vamos,
lo que se dice, un currículum
aparentemente completito. Luego,
su carrera profesional la ha desarrollado,
por supuesto, en las empresas familiares,
donde llego a ser director naviero
y director comercial y de logística.
Sea como sea, en 2021 dio su
primer paso en la política,
fue elegido legislador por la provincia de Santa
Elena, con una candidatura vinculada a partidarios
de Lenin Moreno. En la Asamblea Nacional del
Ecuador, Daniel llegó a presidir la Comisión
de Desarrollo Económico en el Parlamento.)
Más de la mitad de los ecuatorianos depositaron
su confianza en Daniel Noboa, y finalmente
este apellido ha logrado hacerse con la
Jefatura del Estado ecuatoriano.
Y eso nos lleva directamente a una
de las preguntas clave de este vídeo:
¿qué espera hacer Noboa en 17 meses?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
EL PLAN NOBOA)
La candidatura de Noboa estuvo impulsada por la
Acción Democrática Nacional (ADN), un partido
recién creado en noviembre de 2022, que tuvo
que aliarse con otros partidos más pequeños
para poder tener un registro válido
ante el Consejo Nacional Electoral.
Ojito con los nombres, hablamos del Movimiento
Verde Ético Revolucionario y Democrático y el
Movimiento Pueblo, Igualdad y Democracia..
En este sentido, Noboa se presenta como
un político de centro, y aunque él se ha
referido a sí mismo como un socialdemócrata,
lo cierto es que desarrollo una campaña
donde la ideología tuvo muy poco peso.
Digamos que evitó entrar en debates dogmáticos.
Cuestión de pragmatismo político supongo.
Mucha gente especialmente el correísmo
quiere encasillarme en una derecha
cuando nuestro proyecto político es un
proyecto de Centro izquierda es un
progresismo responsable es una social
democracia moderada es la libre empresa
con responsabilidad social
En su plan de gobierno, podemos ver
algunas medidas de corte progresista,
como por ejemplo el incremento del salario mínimo,
la promoción de la negociación colectiva
del trabajo, o el establecimiento de leyes
más severas que sancionen la evasión fiscal
y permitan que el estado recaude más dinero.
Asimismo, Noboa también ha prometido llevar a
cabo una “revisión exhaustiva” de las políticas
de inversión de los fondos de jubilación para que
el Estado pueda intervenir y mejorar el sistema
de pensiones. Un sistema que actualmente
tiene una composición mixta, en la que
participan tanto el Instituto Ecuatoriano
de Seguridad Social como fondos privados.
(Otra faceta que ha destacado en la campaña
de Noboa han sido las propuestas en torno la
diversidad. Este candidato se ha comprometido
a promover la integración de los inmigrantes,
reconocer las nacionalidades
indígenas y promover activamente
la no discriminación de la población LGTBQ)
Es decir, que hablamos de un candidato que
en gran medida encajaría con el típico perfil
de la socialdemocracia europea. Tiene gracia
que el correismo haya perdido contra un
candidato socialdemócrata, ¿no os parece?
Eso sí, en el terreno económico y de
empresas su perfil es mucho más promercado.
Y desde luego defiende
férreamente la dolarización.
C2 (“La protección de la dolarización es crucial,
dado que una economía estable y predecible es un
requisito fundamental para atraer inversión,
tanto interna como externa, y generar empleo.
Para proteger y reforzar la dolarización, es
fundamental mantener la disciplina fiscal y
la responsabilidad en la gestión de las finanzas
públicas. Además, se debe buscar incrementar las
reservas internacionales, lo que proporcionará
una red de seguridad en caso de shocks económicos
externos.” Plan de Gobierno de Daniel Noboa)
En última instancia, su perfil de empresario
lo ha convertido en un líder cómodo
para los sectores productivos. Además,
ha situado como una de sus grandes prioridades
atraer la inversión extranjera, especialmente
en el campo de la energía y el petróleo.
Sin embargo, 17 meses es muy poco tiempo. Y no
dudéis que eso es algo que el propio Noboa tiene
muy claro. Quizás por eso los dos temas clave que
busque durante su presidencia serán primero,
hacer cambios en el sistema educativo.
Hoy en día de trescientos cuarenta mil
jóvenes que aplican a una universidad pública,
solo 140.000 obtuvieron un cupo universitario,
hay 200.000 jóvenes hoy en día de 18 años que
no tuvieron un cupo en una universidad pública
¿Qué tipo de cambios? Pues, por ejemplo, Noboa
ha prometido incrementar el gasto público y la
inversión en educación superior. Según el nuevo
presidente, esta es la mejor forma de enfrentar
y erradicar la “militancia blanda”. ¿Y qué es la
Militancia blanda? Pues básicamente los jóvenes
que son manejados por los grupos de narcos.
Lo que nos lleva directamente al segundo tema
clave que podemos esperar en
su presidencia: la seguridad.
¿Y sabéis qué? Creo que aquí una imagen vale más
que cualquier cosa que podamos decir, fijaos.
En los últimos años, la criminalidad en
Ecuador se ha disparado y está batiendo
todos los registros históricos. El número
de homicidios por 100 mil habitantes se
ha multiplicado prácticamente por 5 en
los últimos 5 años. Locura, ¿verdad?
Pues para intentar poner freno a este
desmadre, Noboa ha prometido reorganizar y
mejorar los servicios de inteligencia para que
se puedan realizar operativos de alto nivel,
algo que hoy por hoy no parece que las
fuerzas de seguridad sean capaces de hacer:
El Ecuador no tiene una
agencia inteligencia consolidada tiene
inteligencia de la policía inteligencia
de los militares inteligencia que se
reporta el presidente de la república
como todo está desarticulado no se puede
dar la fórmula para que la policía y los
militares puedan atacar a las
organizaciones narco delictivas
Asimismo, también ha prometido impulsar
una reforma del Código Penal para mejorar
la situación de los procesados
sin sentencia y los delincuentes
no violentos. La idea es incluir nuevos
tipos, penas alternativas a la prisión
para los delitos no violentos. ¿Por
qué? Pues entre otras cosas, porque
las cárceles del país ya no dan más de sí.
Las cárceles ecuatorianas están saturadas y
los responsables no dan abasto. En
cierto modo, eso explica que cada
dos por tres se produzcan peleas de bandas,
asesinatos de presos y masacres carcelarias.
De hecho, Noboa quiere segmentar a los presos
por su nivel de peligrosidad. E incluso ha
propuesto meter a los más peligrosos
en barcos carcelarios. ¿Qué os parece?
En cualquier caso, como veis, hablamos
de políticas que en general buscan dar
resultados relativamente rápidos. Al fin y al
cabo, una caída en las tasas de criminalidad y
alguna mejora educativa serían dos banderas
electorales fantásticas para el 2025.
Y por eso estos dos campos serán
casi seguro su prioridad número 1
Es verdad que un año y medio no se puede
cambiar el mundo se puede pero sí se
pueden cambiar varias cosas claves
reducir la violencia darle oportunidad a
la juventud
Ahora bien, Noboa no gobernará solo… el
correísmo sigue al acecho. Dos elecciones
en las que han competido a cara de perro
hacen que el fantasma de Rafael Correa
siga muy presente en los círculos de poder
en Ecuador… y la pregunta es ¿Qué significó
este nuevo revés para Rafael Correa? ¿Por qué la
sociedad, ante el fracaso de Lasso, no le dio un
voto de confianza al correísmo? ¿Es realmente
imposible el regreso de Correa al Ecuador?
Pues atentos.
(T3: ¿EL FIN DEL CORREÍSMO?)
Rafael Correa llegó al poder en el
año 2006, cuando justamente logró
derrotar al padre de Daniel, Álvaro
Noboa. Logró completar tres mandatos,
convirtiéndose en la figura hegemónica en la
política ecuatoriana. Su poder parecía ilimitado.
Sin embargo, en 2017 su aliado y
sucesor, Lenin Moreno, cambio de rumbo,
y diferentes investigaciones judiciales
señalaron a Correa como el responsable
de multimillonarias tramas de corrupción.
Por eso desde el año 2018 los tribunales
ecuatorianos exigen su detención, aunque él
vive como refugiado político en Bruselas.
(Desde entonces, su partido, la Revolución
Ciudadana, RC, ha continuado haciendo campaña
y ha sido la principal oposición a
Lenin Moreno y a Guillermo Lasso.
Sin embargo, con Correa fuera del país,
RC no ha estado ni cerca de repetir su
resultado electoral de 2013, cuando logró
ganar en primera vuelta. En 2017 ganaron,
sí, pero aquello solo sirvió para llevar al
ahora anticorreista, Lenin Moreno, al poder. )
En esta última ocasión, RC se presentó a
las elecciones con la candidatura de Luisa
González. Sin embargo, como ya hemos dicho, la
elección presidencial de Ecuador estuvo repleta de
candidatos independientes y de pequeños partidos
unidos por un tema común: el anticorreismo.
Es lo que el propio Rafael Correa
calificó como “poderes enormes”.
N3 (Patria querida, Patria Grande: Esta vez
no lo logramos. Enfrentamos poderes enormes.
Hasta se asesinó a un candidato para evitar
nuestra victoria. La traición de Lenín Moreno
sigue causando estragos, pero que nadie dude
de que, al final, Ecuador volverá a la senda
del desarrollo e integración latinoamericana.
¡Hasta la victoria siempre! Rafael Correa)
Pero llegados a este punto, tenemos que ir algo
más despacio. Esta nueva derrota
tiene un tinte algo diferente.
El liderazgo de Luisa González ha renovado
gran parte de la cúpula RC, un partido
donde ya comienza a sonar la necesidad de ganar
autonomía respecto a la imagen de Rafael Correa.
Amigos y amigas, pensad que estamos hablando de
qué ligados al expresidente, su techo electoral
parece ser no mayor del 47% del voto, algo
que los deja muy cerca de ganar un potencial
ballotage. Algunas voces dentro del partido
creen que solo será posible pasar de ese nivel si
Correa se hace definitivamente a un lado.
Prueba de este cambio de rumbo es el tono
con el que el correísmo ha reconocido la derrota
en 2021 y 2023. Fijaos en la enorme diferencia:
Estaremos atentos ante cualquier intento
de usar al estado para beneficio de
pocos privilegiados estaremos como
siempre lo hemos hecho defendiendo a las
grandes mayorías al pueblo digno al
pueblo ecuatoriano
El Ecuador Necesita trabajar con
la bandera amarillo azul y rojo
Cuente con
nuestros votos en la asamblea para las
reformas legales para la seguridad para
salud para Educación
Amigos, entre la victoria de Noboa, y la posible
restructuración de RC, el panorama político
ecuatoriano podría estar cambiando rápidamente,
La pregunta es, ¿Qué podemos esperar a nivel
institucional en estos 17 meses? ¿Se producirá
un nuevo bloqueo legislativo? ¿Fue realmente la
muerte cruzada una buena idea? Pues veámoslo.
(T4: UN NUEVO HORIZONTE)
Amigos y amigas, ya sabéis que aquí en VPK
tenemos una premisa: ocuparnos de los temas
clave de la agenda internacional. Pues,
¿sabéis qué? Latinoamérica últimamente
no deja de darnos trabajo.
El estallido social en Chile,
el regreso de Lula al poder, el intento de golpe
de Estado de Pedro Castillo, el desmoronamiento
del peronismo en Argentina… Por momentos la
región parece ingobernable. Y, desde luego,
Ecuador no es precisamente un oasis en medio de
toda esa realidad… Aunque con algunos matices.
En las últimas elecciones, Ecuador
acaba de registrar una participación
electoral récord. Digamos que los
ecuatorianos tienen ganas de cambio.
Sin embargo, los ecuatorianos no solo asistieron
masivamente a votar, sino que la opción vencedora
parece representar una clara ruptura con el
pasado. Es decir, Ecuador parecería contar
ahora con un nuevo proyecto político, que no
remite ni a Correa, ni a Moreno, ni a Lasso:
Me dicen que soy Lassista
otros me dicen soy Correísta otros me
dicen que soy Leninista al final del día
yo soy Pro Ecuador y tengo mi propia
determinación y tengo mi propio proyecto
político
Aquí Ecuador ha roto con la tendencia regional.
Si Perú entró en una carrera de autodestrucción
tras la caída de Pedro Pablo Kuczynski; si
Brasil tras la destitución de Dilma Rousseff,
le dio su voto de confianza a Bolsonaro,
en Ecuador han apostado por la moderación.
Claro que todavía hay un problema:
la composición legislativa.
El bloque de Noboa (ADN) a penas cuenta con 14
diputados, en un espacio donde se necesitan al
menos 69 legisladores para tener una mayoría
mínima. Así que si realmente quiere sacar
adelante reformas le va a tocar tener que
dialogar mucho con el resto de partidos.
Sobre la mesa, los números están servidos
para que se produzca un nuevo bloqueo
parlamentario. Y es aquí donde entra en acción
la campaña de Noboa. Al llegar como moderado,
sin haber chocado abiertamente con
nadie, ni siquiera con el correísmo,
le da una oportunidad. ¿Sabrá aprovecharla?
Por ahora, la victoria de Noboa le ha dado a
Ecuador una salida institucional y pacifica
a una grave crisis política. Las cartas están
echadas. Solo el tiempo nos dirá si se
cumplen o no las expectativas generadas.
Pero, ahora, llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Qué piensas sobre el perfil “de centro de
Noboa? ¿Crees que es el perfil adecuado para
liderar Ecuador durante los próximos 17 meses?
¿Volveremos a ver un nuevo bloqueo político?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y ahora si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante no olvides darle a like y suscribirte
a VisualPolitik si es que aún no lo has hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.